many students face back to school
jitters this time of the year but for
some kids a return to the classroom can
bring out more serious anxiety a recent
study found that anxiety in kids has
increased by more than 29 percent in
recent years now kids will be
readjusting to the classroom after their
previous two school years were disrupted
by the pandemic laura phillips is a
senior director and neuropsychologist at
the child mind institute and she joins
us right now good morning good morning
so how should parents approach
a conversation about mental health that
sometimes can be uncomfortable it can be
uncomfortable so i think it's really
important that when parents are starting
a conversation with their kids about the
return to school if they ask questions
that are open-ended rather than a
leading question so rather than saying
something like are you feeling really
nervous about your first day of school
next week we encourage parents to ask
something like how are you feeling about
going back into the classroom next week
what if you say how are you feeling and
you get the kind of teenage response of
like
fine i'm all right then you can probe a
little bit more um and and it it's
possible if they're feeling fine but i
think that you can also um discuss some
of the things that might be different
about the school year and see if that
triggers anything um that they bring up
i think that one thing that feels a
little bit different we know that last
year i think was really the big year
that most kids went back into the
classroom after a year and a half of
either remote or hybrid instruction so
being back in the classroom this year
might be less anxiety provoking than in
the past although that we know that mass
mandates are a little bit different this
year we also know that
a lot of schools that pis that had uh
sort of paused extracurricular
activities in the past have begun to
reinstate those so there are other
things about this school year that might
be different that you can start
conversations about with kids what are
some of the signs that we should be
looking for when detecting anxiety and
then what once you've identified it sure
so they're the the classic things that
we tend to see in kids
who might be experiencing anxiety some
kids might come out and say it although
we encourage parents to look for things
like overt changes in behavior if you're
noticing an increase in irritability an
increase in frustration or more kids who
are more easily triggered by things
that otherwise they might have been able
to roll off their back a little bit more
easily changes in sleep so kids who are
having a hard time falling asleep at
night who might be waking up
periodically through them out the night
or even waking up much earlier than
usual in the morning
we often we often notice that kids are
increased showing clinginess or they
might be showing having complaints of
stomach aches or headaches that they
don't typically have god's making up
excuses um
i know you can see what happens at your
house you're going to school
you suggest a test run for kids
what is what does that look like sure so
part of the anxiety is the unknown so um
to the extent that we can help kids to
preview what the school year might look
like can be really really helpful in
relieving kids discomfort around the new
school year so if kids are going to a
new school for the first time maybe
doing a drive by the school walking to
the school so they can sort of see what
that initial introduction will be
introducing them to their teachers
yeah there are some school districts
around the country that have uh mental
health days so you could take a sick day
in essence and you can be flagged as a
mental health day you can just not go uh
is that helpful do you think for kids
it's a really great question i think
it's really important to think about how
those days are used um we know and then
you actually
introduced at the beginning of the
segment that that rates of anxiety are
rising pretty significantly over the
past couple of years um and everyone
benefits from taking a pause and having
an opportunity to recharge as needed
especially kids who are under tremendous
stress um now relative to uh in the past
so it's used as a moment to recharge i
think it can have a really healthy place
in the school year if it's used as an
escape from something that's anxiety
provoking then that ends up reinforcing
the anxiety
so um we want to just be mindful about
how those days are used some really
great tips there i like the idea of
going to the school get your mind set
ready to go back yeah and then you got
to get into bed earlier absolutely
that's tough
whole different conversation well it's
green time monitoring right there turn
that phone off yeah
yeah laura phillips thank you so much
for joining us thanks for having me
absolutely